[Applause]
i love designing and helping to make
every day a little bit
prettier for people i believe that a
budget should never get in the way
between you and creating joy in your
space it's effective it's important
and today i'm showing you how to design
like a pro
for under 30 bucks meet sarah
she has a design dilemma let's watch
hi drew i have a design dilemma
my entryway i feel like it's super dull
and
uninviting and it's gotten to the point
that i'm using the kitchen back
door to let people come into my house so
something's got to be done but i don't
want to spend a ton of money
so i need your advice drew what should i
do
oh say hello to sarah hi farah
oh what a pleasure drew what a pleasure
oh you're wearing the beautiful yellow
shirt we love yellow around here
it's it's youtube it's your energy
you're such a ball of sunshine that i'm
like you know what let me just put on
some yellow and
feel like sunshine feel like jerusalem
wow i'm wearing the
hello speaking of feel like sunshine um
how do you feel when you're in your
entryway
not like sunshine um as you can see
behind me
right here um it's really dull
it's kind of sad and now with this whole
quarantine situation
like we order stuff we order food we
order
you know all kinds of delivery services
so it's sad
it's kind of depressing we've been kind
of playing with the idea of how do we
decorate on a budget
how do we stick with the budget that we
currently have so it's just confusing
it's confusing space all right i'm going
to show you a couple
little secrets under 30 all right first
we went and got some wall hooks now the
process of this
is that how many times do we throw our
bags on the floor
for me it's all the time and so
this is going to actually improve the
look of that
bag on floor these hooks are actually
called
dowels and you can get them at a
hardware store or a craft store and you
can just paint the tip and guess what it
costs three dollars
okay all right this is one of my
favorite secrets
i went ahead and all these are
is prints and i googled image them this
is a search
anyone can do and all you have to do is
print it out
on semi-decent paper it's like an
endless art store at your fingertips
then you can get a vintage frame or go
to a thrift store
and this whole thing is 23.
that's awesome that looks really
expensive actually but i like that it's
printed
and then find something cylindrical in
your house i promise you there
is something hanging out get some spray
paint and go to town all right
i'll show you
that's it and the can of paint cost
three dollars and fifty cents
so your grand total for all of this is
29.50
and this is why i'm passionate about
design
because it's about the emotional
connection
when we see something that doesn't make
us happy we have to
literally take the time and figure out
how to fix it
because marie kondo is right it does
spark joy
and joy is important it will actually
change your life
okay now i can't help it farah i'm sorry
i did go a little over budget and i got
these ottomans that are actually storage
and this one fits into this one
and then i found this rug and i'm
sending it to you so i hope you like it
oh my god
[Applause]
okay now i want to show you
the before and after pics of your
entryway just from the 30 dollars we
spent
that's it it's really pretty and then
uh if we can bring the new picture up of
what your entryway is going to look like
that looks gorgeous
yeah do you like it i really do
yeah it's it's it's like an adult
entryway so this is fantastic thank you
so much i wasn't expecting that so
thanks
thank you for coming on the show and
giving us your design dilemma i hope
that this brings you a lot of happiness
the kind that you deserve let's make
every day pretty
[Music]